hi everyone and welcome to the corridor
cast today's guest is Harley Morenstein
a longtime friend of mine and an old
youtuber like me we've been on the
platform for about eight years and
learned a lot of interesting things
while doing so Harley's got a wealth of
stories and he's an interesting guy he's
not just the founder of Epic Meal Time
he might be excited to learn about what
else he has seen what else he has heard
and what else he has done and the
interesting insights he has in the world
around us for example what is it like
meeting and working with your heroes and
then what is it like to learn that you
are somebody else's hero and that you
have changed and influenced their life
or for example what's the difference
between Fame and celebrity and what do
you do if one of your friends on
Facebook start saying racist things how
do you deal with it all that and more
with Harley hello everybody and welcome
to the corridor cast is the 3rd episode
with our guest Harley Morenstein now
Harley honest we go pretty far back in
fact I meant Harley right when you're
starting corridor and we basically
journeyed through the Wonderland's of
YouTube together over the past eight
years sometimes holding hands sometimes
just looking each other in the eyes but
generally sharing the adventure Harley
for those for those of the people here
who are not familiar with you how do you
introduce yourself hi my name is Harley
I'm the sauce boss from Epic Meal Time a
cooking show and I pick on YouTube
that's been around for eight years and I
met Nico and Sam like like so long I
remember the day very clearly I came I
went to go work with Freddie I met you
guys and you guys were like oh yeah we
do YouTube also and we're like oh yeah
what do you guys what kind of shows give
me feel like home we only have one video
one video that's so what's your one
video and then I was thinking that Call
of Duty video we're like you guys made
that call of duty it was like the first
time my life for like was you're just
two guys just two guys like and it was a
whole it was like a whole crazy
production this was like an extreme if
you guys aren't deep in corridor like
the deepest this is a deep corridor cut
here it's so deep in front our channel
it's not there anymore it's on Freddie's
channel oh that frozen crossing was on
his yeah we put that on his channel and
he had like 20,000 subs because he had
just gotten partnership and we had spent
like
200 bucks in the video and right boy
sure be nice to have those 200 bucks
back like hey we can upload on your
channel I'll get the ad revenue back
yeah yeah and here we are eight years
later running a business on YouTube yeah
so it's it's insane I it's been fun
being there like knowing Nico and Sam
since the very beginning because in this
industry YouTube Hollywood any industry
I guess it's hard to find like real
people mm-hmm and we've been like
connected for eight years now so for
eight years I've watched and you've
watched and like it's it's always good
to like you know cuz I've been in Canada
they've been here and like to come and
touch basic every year and a half or so
or sometimes more frequently I'm like yo
what's the space like now for you yes
the plan now what what's different
what's changed what about these guys are
those guys or that Chandler or this
company or that company and it's just
yeah we've been through lots of ups and
downs man whoo it's been so long almost
10 years yeah it is really crazy like I
always thought college is gonna be a
long times like men four years at school
that's a long time and not like here I
am 10 years out of college it's like oh
man decade oh yeah we're old guys yeah
realize that like I'm older than 30 how
old 30 old for 30 are you what I yeah
well most people think I'm in my 20s
like when they see us on the channel and
stuff yeah Michaels are just running
around like a bunch of kids still doing
fun things but yeah I turned 33 in a
week okay yeah so I'm 33 also and like
the hardest thing is when I come
streaming video games mm-hmm and I'm
like streaming video games they're like
wow bro get a real job cuz like it'll be
someone maybe that don't know that I
have a real job this this runs like it
tangent with my real job and like so I
just look like some like I look like
this and I'm like playing red dead and
I'm like really enjoying myself and like
people coming but this is just sickening
breath don't you have kids to take care
of them like no no and like all this
comes down to the fact that I'm just
like you know I look like this mm-hmm
then you look at you know I think it's
one thing that we got appreciate at
least we don't like well you and I as
different pages
don't look like this and I'm trying to
get something off the ground yeah you
know what I mean and like I I feel bad
for maybe the mutant people out there or
even and I don't want to go and say like
oh man
you're 33 years old and you're still
trying to be a rapper maybe consider a
new avenue of whatever I don't want to I
don't want to be like that but I do know
that it's an uphill battle for those
people because like you know girls and
clubs or like radio DJs or whatever
they're they're playing like music for
people that are like almost maybe half
our age now you know yeah I was
listening to some girl I'm like oh this
is great song cool music video she's 17
I'm two times that yeah I did seventeen
twice already almost yeah I will say in
the film industry it feels like at least
being in your 30 is the right age cuz
like trying to get a show off the ground
I mean I realize that when you're
pitching a TV show it's no different
than going to the bank and like trying
to tell them that you're a grocery store
they need to get a loan for is going to
be a great success like it's the exact
same thing when you're pitching a TV
show so if you're like 25 years old and
you're trying to go to a studio and get
them to make your show like I'm not
gonna take you seriously even no matter
how good your work is no it's true yeah
it's true that's why like unless you're
unless you're team 10 team 10 yeah then
team 10 you could do it you know if
you're Jake Paul they're like hey man
that sounds like a great idea that's
what it's just you in the corner I need
you just [ __ ] on the floor yeah that'll
get like millions of dollars I did hear
a rumor that maverick merchandise the
numbers are so different now from when
we started this but maverick merchandise
I heard made 40 million dollars in one
month that's crazy last year that's
crazy
I mean imagine the pressure of being
surrounded by so many people just like
eager to make billions of dollars off of
you yeah it's got to be a little
insanity inducing yeah whereas and you
know what like in our case to an extent
it's a bit different there's never been
like just like wow Harley so cool or
Nikko so cool that's just like milk
money out of that it's just like we
provided something I provide a brand you
provide an art whatever it is that
people want to buy into so it is
different yeah
although the 40 million dollars in deals
never really came through what do you
think it is that made like Logan Paul
and Jake Paul so much more popular than
the most popular youtubers when we
started I think it's uh there's a whole
new element of gaming the system that
goes on so like back in the day you know
like before this podcast even started
like Nico had said to me he said if you
if there's anything weird if you say
anything weird that you change your mind
later you know let me know and we could
pull it out and I didn't want a podcast
that stays on date he said the same
thing to me and whenever I did Epic Meal
Time videos I would say like to people
like you know like I'm filming with you
know other creators you yourself whoever
jenna Marbles I think if I if we say
something or do something that you don't
like let me know and I'll pull it out
later whereas in this day and age people
are so keen and so quick to expose one
another in exchange for viewership we
don't have that we didn't have that and
I think like it's like you know it's I
don't want to say it's our it's a
disadvantage but it's something that is
different today
like with theirs I don't want to say
that like we're better or our generation
of YouTube was better it's just
different and in this one there's like
no shame in some of the content that
you'd put out there yeah like it like I
would never put out a video you know
like exposing or or even like I would
never put out a video of me holding the
camera and like looking into the camera
and crying I'm admitting something just
because I know that crying on camera
gets you more views these days you know
what I mean
yeah I would never use like my audience
as a means of therapy for myself to try
and like reach a new audience of people
that you know you know what I'm saying
there's like a whole gaming there and I
understand what it is but I feel are you
and I at least our channels never really
went down that path mm-hmm and in this
day and age like you know like you know
Logan Pauley put on when he put on
glasses and he was able to see color and
he cried for the first time I mean he
saw color for the first time and he
started crying
I was like it's an awesome thing if
that's you know if that's how it plays
up but you know even then like maybe
that's a private thing yeah your first
time doing that what's what's private
would it what is you know yeah maybe
it's just because we do this for living
so we understand the process a little
bit more or maybe people have changed in
like the ubiquity of you know cameras in
your pocket has changed this and I just
haven't realized that but it feels
disingenuous to be capturing those
emotions because you had to consciously
take out your camera and cameras aren't
they take out hit the button it's take
it out turn it on make sure the
battery's charged make sure you got
space in the card oh I have other
footage on the card maybe we need to
dump it okay is it in focus now it's in
focus my in the right frame right I'm in
the right frame right hit record how's
the lighting Lighting's good is it quiet
it's quiet okay start the tears and then
being like guys I don't know how I'm
going to start this video it's already
broad step 15 now of starting the video
so let's just keep going
you know you keeping those extra bits
where it's like I don't know how I'm
gonna tell you guys this and it's like
you know how to edit you know that you
would normally edit all that part out
but that's part of the game like the
manipulation aspect and you know I
always thought that you know videos were
to be fun fun things and I definitely
think that it's cool that there's some
videos out there that some people can
relate to I always get like weird when I
see like a video and it's giving people
like like I even feel we were just
saying right now I wouldn't give don't
give don't get people like mental health
advice I feel weird even saying cuz I
know so little on the subject how can I
say to say it or don't say it I don't
know what's best or what's not best but
I always feel weird when I see like you
know a some like crazy ass youtuber like
preaching to the audience about like
mental health and how it is and how it
should be and how it chime I know this
is gonna get a ton of views because this
is like a sweet spot but at the same
time like you're you're like you know
you're are you the guy right now to be
saying are you the girl right now to be
saying that to the audience and I
sometimes when I'm like are they playing
the game right now am I getting too
caught up and being like don't do that
or should I just be like Oh respect
their grind they're doing the grind
they're milking the system you know like
Who am I like I you know there's there's
hungry people out there and we'll
like 5,000 bacon strips and be like oh
so it's not like I have like a moral
high-ground but at the same time like I
know there's this I don't know I said I
don't know like maybe there's this like
it's just it's it's more of a game now I
feel and people play the game more and I
are you even we make we made videos we
made content now there's a lot of the
game involved and sometimes i click
things like my guilty pleasure I'll
watch keemstar videos I'll watch tromler
i watch all that you're probably smarter
than me I feel like you know you don't
watch that [ __ ] I don't watch that stuff
make you stupid brother listen have I go
down those holes I grew up like they
have a game appeared mentality about art
and music where it's like if I didn't
like the person creating the art of
music I would just give up on the
product they made like is able to s able
to I guess make that sacrifice sometimes
my little bits of Hippo criticism here
and there but yeah III feel you know
that I have been a [ __ ] of HIPAA
criticism what that like you won't catch
me dancing to Chris Brown mm-hmm even if
he makes like a really cool track cuz
I'll always remember the crazy pictures
of Rihanna and I'm a huge little Dickey
fan I remember my little Dickie made the
song Chris Brennan was like so funny and
so good and so excellent but at the same
time I was kind of like you could have
made that song with anyone you know but
like it's so weird to do it there but
then you know I always feel we're don't
I'm gonna go and like take some sort of
moral high ground it's like who are you
you know a bacon guy on the Internet
shut up man just watch the video you
know like an out like what's another one
that I saw a Harry Potter fantastic
beasts hmm you know there's this whole
like alleged stuff with Johnny Depp I
don't know much about it but like all
these people be like don't go see the
movie cuz you know he's not a good
person you know and I'm like yeah don't
it's not a good person but I know I'll
watch the movie I will end up watching
the movie but I I never want to make
like I never want like me to be
consuming content to be some sort of
political stance on something or
whatever and it ends up being even
everything I'm saying right now is this
in itself and I don't want it to be you
know sometimes they just think it's so
ignorant but I'm just like why can't
everyone be happy why can't we be
chilled why can't we make videos based
on video games back in the day and not
be like yo my brother had sex with my
girlfriend and now my family's torn
apart and I'm telling all the
ten-year-old kids watching my vlog about
it
buy my merchandise you know yeah maybe
that's why I never sold 40 mil I never
gamed the system that hard yeah like you
know a moment you're much no much
merchandise you would sell if like Team
Nico and you just punch Sam in the face
one time think about it well yeah I have
this theory that you know film media in
general it's always been about trying to
make something feel real so back in the
day before cameras existed it's just
theater plays right you have to be a
good test being you have to go on the
stage and you have to feel the emotion
you're giving a performance but you're
also trying to make authentic emotions
happen and the more authentic the
emotion the better of an actor you are
and then the camera comes along it's
like oh we can make these scenes feel
real we can capture real images now
these pretend make-believe plays feel
even more real oh we can get real props
we can get real set so we can get
lighting we can put you know get our
actors put them in costumes you know we
have costumes we're gonna try to make
them feel like we're doing a scene for
real and that's evolving that's evolving
that's evolved to where we are now to
where the closest we have to making
something real is literally capturing it
in the moment as if it's real now most
of the stuff is still fake like a lot of
stuff is still staged even like the
voice I'm putting on with you like our
conversations are not this tight when
we're just hanging out they are not this
cohesive and I am NOT this articulate
but we we still elevate slightly when
the cameras on but like the the art
style of the vlog and of youtube these
days is like the closest thing you have
to seeing something real and I find
myself sitting through like two minutes
or three minutes of downtime waiting for
something real to happen because
somebody puts wait for it in the title
and like I would walk away from a TV
show if it did that like because to me
it's fake they could have edited it
edited it but this video is real
something real is gonna happen so I'm
watch so whenever I people want to ask
about vlogging I know exactly what you
mean people like be like oh like you
know people closer to us because I feel
like it's one generation or one half
generation after us to really embrace
the vlogging you know YouTube was vlogs
and I feel like our era came in and was
like no we could be better than that
let's make shows yeah let's give like
Food Network or action shows a run for
their money
you know and I feel like we did that but
then the generation or half generation
after us brought vlogs back to an extent
and he started to do that and I know
other creators like us what would ask me
that because I started vlogging you know
which I went to Shay Carl who was before
and during us I was like oh what how do
you vlog like I asked my vlogging and
stuff and like - what you just said I
would tell people like take the camera
out and it's weird the cameras out
you're like hey what up I'm here with
Nikko and it's weird and it sucks but
once that cameras up for 30 seconds real
things start to happen yeah
now even though like it's an awkward
real thing that wouldn't happen with the
camera being there there are real
interactions because there's no
guidelines and it's just the camera
sitting there and like a lot of my vlogs
like end up being that like you know
like I'm gonna leave that whole piece in
where you know you were set you were to
like we mean anything we're filming like
right before and like it was he was like
I'll do this I one of the park asses up
do that I'm gonna put the whole chunk up
I like to not edit I'm like that's it
right there that's the real moment that
was us like breaking it down how's the
best way to go forward with this night
and I agree it's like there's like TV
vlogs they're completely different but
we would walk away from or not walk away
from are so different from the content
that gets put up nowadays like people
don't like on TV wouldn't want to see
like a real life you know or at least we
thought wouldn't when we were growing up
watch like you know a brother have sex
with his little brother's girlfriend and
like rap about it you know it's like you
back in our day it's like that's kind of
nauseating and messed up you know yeah
but like in this day and age and that's
why I say it's my guilty pleasure I'm
like
drama lured him like yo [ __ ] his
girlfriend likes his little brother but
if my brother did that you know
and then my dad vlogged his vlog being
like well it's my boys always
competition careful or your big
brother's gonna [ __ ] your girlfriend
like do you think that's putting people
more in touch with the human condition
and what it means to be human or do you
think it's just messing everybody up
ai ai ai ai don't want to say like once
again like it's always I was gonna put
in perspective leg Who am I where do I
come from what is my voice I can only
assume that traditional TV personalities
on Food Network
would watch my channel of us making at a
turbot like a six-foot robot made of
tater tots and like you know and they'd
probably look at them like that's just
ridiculous there's no that's just mass
consumption there's no complete
disregard for culinary world and this so
I can't ever get on a high horse but at
the same time I could just you know if
you understand that that's where I'm
coming from and I get that about me I
could look at it and be like yeah I
think it messes up some [ __ ] I feel like
it messes up some [ __ ] like you know I
was you know I watched that whole Shane
Dawson documentary stuff hmm and the one
thing LLL zni it cuz it sounds like a
movie script but like that like a list
said to look and she was like cuz Logan
had limit at jokes you don't watch drama
but I close every little catch-up here
welcome to had sex with Jake's
ex-girlfriend that's his little brother
so that's like a big deal oh that's
that's the little brother you're talking
yeah yeah ex-girlfriend and she felt bad
about it and she said to Logan she was
like can we not like can we no that was
a big mistake we shouldn't have done
that can we not talk about who's like
not talk about he's like I'm gonna vlog
it ooh and she was like oh please don't
do that like why was Jay he's like sound
[ __ ] maverick mmm and like that
sounds for you yeah it bothers a merge
for me that's like that's like what
wrestling is that's wrestling yeah but
that's like not it's you know wrestling
is a show you know what I mean yeah
these are like real lives like you said
you were set you said it like you know a
bit earlier in the podcast that people
forget that did you see that before the
party already started recording Oh Nico
let's recreate the moment for everybody
yes is it a crazy how like when you're
looking at
shots online of people like you don't
feel like people anymore like when you
see something a gift it's just effect
simile of a person a character that just
exists or that blip of a moment but you
forget that I'd say that gift is still a
real person it's true it's totally true
which is why sometimes people come up to
me and they touch me on the street a
stranger someone will come fee and grab
my arm and shake me and go south spouse
I turn around I'm like hey how are you
and then they walk away and I'll you
know I'll like look people I'm with them
like I just touched me I don't know him
like that's people they don't realize
cuz every Tuesday for the last eight
years I've been like we're friends
drinking and eating together yeah
so I know I agree with that people
forget that they're people and that's
truly what it is and like in this
particular scenario we're just like oh
man Jake Paul ha he's so what an [ __ ]
he's not he's being an idiot on the news
channel mmm and you know and it's like
man when I was 20 years old or a lot of
people I know and they're 20 years old
like weren't the coolest guys or nicest
people yeah growing up and imagine if
like my older brother was like [ __ ]
my girlfriend and my dad was like
straighten up put on your game face
vlog like and because his dad's like
doesn't blogs too like you messed up the
whole family like that and like the mom
makes video and they're like she's like
be sexier and like all these things it's
just like I could just imagine I like
thank God
and I think mealtime happened when I was
25 I thank God all the time that like it
I was a full-time teacher for years
before epicMealTime that epicMealTime
didn't happen when I was 21 mm-hmm I
would have killed it instantly I would
ruined everything so fast you know yeah
I was I just get the vibe here probably
a bit more of a responsible person I
could be you might be a little bit more
reserved with your actions
I was I'm like Gilles [ __ ] do it
right now man roll the camera baby no if
I was 20 years old and the same thing
happened yeah I'd probably just speed
well it's a little different cuz I was
like a big action movie kid I mean I
still am an action movie guy but like if
I was 20 years old and somebody came to
me it's like here's a million dollars
make this crazy gunfight movie like I
would just get taken advantage oh so
hard in the Hollywood system I'd be like
burnt out and broke by the time I'm 22
you know
percent exactly there's so many things
that like I I'm happy with my timing and
you know you being the same age similar
to your timing mm-hmm is a big deal cuz
like time is a huge deal you know you
know like bad baby
bad baby bad baby cash me outside
that girl Kashmir side how about that
she went on dr. Phil with a lot we
talked about so much you and I we got it
we always got a cover video games and
sci-fi and movies that we never I never
share with you all of the stupid things
I watching the trip but who's that girl
that went on dr. Phil okay
and she was like Kashmir sign how about
that and then she ended up being this
huge thing and like she's a better
tagline that was her tagline and then
she like made rap videos and stuff and
mmm
she was 14 and I would see people on my
facebook list writers and stuff and in
Hollywood and they'd be like oh I can't
leave this stupid little [ __ ] is like
so famous why we making this trash
famous blah blah blah mmm and I always
have to gentleman be like that's a 14
year old girl if you don't like that she
is like this is our world it's not like
you can't get mad that it's her like
it's us like this is like it's it's even
like the box that she is growing up in
is the box that we created we made this
box of YouTube and viral videos and it
was funny in the leg be like Oh
Chocolate Rain haha let's shared a
million times or like Oh hide your kids
hide your let's share it like over the
decade yeah we made this box and this
box can make a girl like her thrive and
where she tells dr. Phil's guests cash
me outside how about that and she ends
up being like a big deal and she can
make rap videos and all that and
everyone gets so mad like I and calls
her trash and maybe it's because I used
to be a teacher I'm like that's like a
young girl mm-hmm you know there's like
she was in a bad place before this and
we just made this work she didn't want
things she got a TMZ came up to her
outside once and they were like oh Kim
Kardashian wants to work with you the
Kardashians and she was like I don't
want to work at Kardashians they just
had sex on tape like no one cares about
them whatever I'm walked away and I was
like that like only a fourteen-year-old
could be so bold anyone no matter what
even if you bash you'd be like
Kardashian work with me oh my gosh like
we get a cook on Epic Meal Time like you
know I'm sure maybe under some
circumstance be a dope agitated
Kardashian's in a corner digital video
you guys showing her how to like hold a
Chris vector or something know how to
reload it for the video
I don't know man I don't know what
happened I'd like to feel like yeah
screw that it you know like the
Kardashians but then I'm like the
content would be to fire orders oh man
yeah good the problem is like I'll get
these like ideas like whoa be cool we
had this personality mainly so I could
like parody them or make fun of them
yeah and you know like put them in a
space or a position that like you would
never expect to see them in because it's
so hilarious to imagine them as that you
know I treat them like actors yeah I'm
in their control the character and have
the character do something funny and
gets a reaction but like yeah that's
tough would never pan out in real life
but like for her they're like it was
just like it's like makeup or who knows
what she didn't even ask what was she
was just like no no I was like that's
commendable
ballsy that's commendable you know she
does like outlandish stuff but she went
on dr. Phil for a second appearance and
she walks out and it was dr. Phil got
rid of the whole audience and she came
out and she was like where's the
audience
dr. Phil's like I thought that you would
respond better if we didn't have the
audience and she says you ain't got in a
show if you ain't got no hos oh and I
thought that was like no that's like
like that's funny it is fine even though
she's a caricature and like you know
it's a little irresponsible that a14 no
girl is doing that is there's a timing
and a brain pattern there and it's funny
and I actually think that that that
could be like she could be like like
cultivated better and she could you know
go down a path and I was like oh she
needs help but then she goes on to say
how a lot of the bad things that
happened were her mom's doing mm-hmm
that she wanted to use her power to stop
people from being bullied cuz she gets
bullied a lot now and she used to be
bullied and it was like no one's
coaching her on that and she is a good
person she wanted to people not be
bullied and so she so what she's funny
and she's crazy and she's like you know
like she says stuff and like you know we
could even go down the route that she
like you know appropriates a different
culture or whatever but like the truth
is like you know there's something good
here it's a 14 year old girl she's still
growing up
how could we just be so quick to bash
and even though Jake Paul is like seven
years older I was always like well I'm
like the guy's 20 years old and he's got
like tens of millions of dollars mm-hmm
you know do you know why it's called
team 10 I can't tell me there's ten
digits in a billion Oh actually like
it's not like that's true so it's
unfortunate but that's like the funniest
thing that's no different you ever watch
Silicon Valley that's the Tres comas
exactly but it's real yes look I'm
valleys like YouTube is not Silicon
Valley but it's closed so close so so
very close yeah yeah enough to make this
show both scary and funny on it yeah
that show is oh my god I love that show
it's so good so funny and it's so on the
nose and like yeah that's literally
touch team ten like the three comma Club
like you know I thought that was funny
and I always like you know like for me
it's like well what do we expect we're
mad mm-hmm we live in a world where we
put him there and now we're mad that
he's acting like a 20 year old about it
what do you want him to be like how
should he be like and then no one's ever
gonna sympathize with him but I can't
help and maybe it's because I make
youtube videos to me because I've been
on the receiving end of like crazy
trauma or people be like Europe you are
a bad person Harley because you did this
or that not knowing how everything else
is but in this particular scenario it's
like men he's like you know has the
relationship with his brother and it's
dad everything is on camera everything
is there you know it's like I don't know
I feel like it's uh it's not as simple
as just like oh he's a douchebag
yeah you know what I mean I wonder if
there's like there's probably not any
balance there like other people have
that balance where they go on camera and
like they have these extreme moments but
who they are on camera is different than
who are they are in the in real life and
there's a balance in real life that they
obviously hide for the camera and
there's people who are just they've
become so like they live in it so much
that when the cameras on that's just who
they are like this person that they
become you can't always tell the
difference you know when watching the
videos on YouTube if somebody has
embrace that role so much they are now
method acting for all of their life
versus just turning
character on and playing a character
just for that video and it's scary when
people don't realize that you should
just you don't have to act don't to be a
method actor for your entire life to
just be able to make it work on camera
just practice being the character want
to be on camera do some writing like
it's okay to be fake
it's okay to fake it because that'd be
nice it's all fake it's all accident
yeah that's the biggest thing I actually
see I don't know them well enough to
know like when it stops or if it stops
or how it I had a feeling it doesn't
stop anymore yeah but the cameras are
always on there that's the thing is like
there is no you have so much off-camera
time in your life you know know
something I had to learn as well like
when the camera is off when it's not a
thing you know I used to go and hang out
with her youtubers and be like [ __ ] I
have to act like the sauce boss or
they'll tell people that like you know
I'm [ __ ] nerd in real life so I'd go
and I'm like yo we're the [ __ ] I
let's get drunk and in my head I'm like
I got drunk last night I really don't
wanna get drunk give it to me I want a
hamburger or something like I just ate
lunch I mean this better but like I was
like god forbid people know that I'm a
real person
mhm and I had that it like 26 27 yeah I
know but I agree it's like it was it was
a learning skill but imagine that like
being like 17 18 19 20 and being there
and living in a house called the teen 10
house where there's like 40 people that
all have cameras there like we always
want the cameras on like you and it's
like I could just imagine like you know
we're gonna we're gonna make some weird
mutated people that's for sure
yes what's going on now in life is
YouTube this is our fault it was your
stupid Call of Duty video that you put
up did this you talk about YouTube
ruining the world I read this essay back
when I was in school it was talking
about gatekeepers of media and before
the internet you had you know ABC NBC
CBS I can't remember how many more there
were like that's the big three
I guess Fox to a certain extent and WB
but there were gatekeepers of media
though you don't really only get the
news from those shows and so the people
in charge of the news would decide what
was important what wasn't and when was
it the right time to put out a story
that was
as popular something people might not
like but everybody needs to hear it or
it's just everybody to get cultured a
little bit so I'm gonna throw something
out that's not super entertaining but we
need to take a moment and teach people
this moment and so you have these
gatekeepers that you know ideally they
are benefactor II you know ideally they
were being helpful or trying to
enlighten people but there's also you
could argue that they could also be bias
they could manipulate the system they
could control the information and so
there's that you know freedom side of it
the freedom of information side of it
which kind of rallies against the
concept of gatekeepers and so is talking
about how the internet doesn't really
have that issue doesn't really have
gatekeepers it's a free information for
all the flip side of that is that you
only seek out information that you want
and there's also no one's stopping you
from putting out fake information false
information now back then and honestly
still a little bit now I'm all I was all
about you know freedom you know let
people do what they want let them live
their own lives I got the libertarian
streak in me you know let people
disseminate the information they wanted
to semmen ate and rely on people to pick
up what they want to pick up looking at
the internet now and seeing how it's
evolved over these ten years of not
having gatekeepers it's not having any
centralized information so to speak word
what side do you feel like you would
stand on do you feel like you'd stand on
bring back some of this
curating of media or do you think we
should keep going down this realm of
just letting people find their way in
the Wild West of online I think that's
such a excellent question because like
you know what like I feel like we are I
feel like we're in a weird gray area
right now and the gray area is that
things will be different I think in
obviously things will be different in
like five ten years from now yeah but
things are different now in the sense
that like Facebook was not a place where
people got a lot of their news Facebook
was like where you went to go you know
speak to family members whatever whatnot
but I have some some rules that I
operate on her and I can't I can't go
left or right on this decision right now
I can't decide I'm just kind of like
let's see it play out more before I I
draw my line in the
and where I am let's see where it goes
but I do offer it on a couple rules I go
on Facebook sometimes and someone will
say something that is like outlandish to
me like to me is racist mm-hmm I think
it's racist and I understand that they
don't think it's racist and they'll say
something racist on Facebook and I know
this person and it'll get a bunch of
likes and people will go in their
comment section and be like yeah finally
someone right wah I can't believe people
think this is racist it's not racist
into my head I'm like it's definitely
racist mm-hmm but I don't think that
person is bad or I don't even think that
person is racist but what they're saying
is to me a racist thing for example I
have friends that will remove that
person from their friends list my rule
is I would not I will go on the comments
section and I will state how I feel or I
would just be like you know I don't
think you're racist or whatever and I
don't want to offend you if I think that
the statement is ignorant but it is a
racist thing and I just want to let you
know that that's how I feel because we
are friends you respect me and I think
it's important to know that in the
echo-chamber of Facebook and how you
could so quickly create your own echo
chamber when people remove others from
their friends list because they don't
like what they say I always think it's
important to know that you know for that
person like the way I see them like that
guy he needs me he doesn't know he needs
me he needs me to say there are people
that you respect out there that disagree
with you and think this is racist even
though you have all these thumbs up in
all these comments I'm the type of
person that will put my name there and
say I disagree with you on that and
that's important and then this guy is
important to me because I can't just be
like oh man what there's a black
president racism is dead no look at what
people say on Facebook all the time yeah
so Facebook is a messed up site I go
there a lot people like to just think
that they know everything or that they
are like you know they they really see
how it is or whatever the amount of
times you know you know here's a touchy
one people will go out and be like there
are two genders shut up that's it people
like yeah finally man tell
tell them and I'm just always want to go
in there Blake wait hold on I know from
what I learned in kindergarten boys have
penis girls have vagina but isn't there
something more at work here something
more at play you know like psychiatrists
psychologists they change like you know
the DSM every year half year there's
always like new diagnosis is that a
disease is that is that something wrong
we don't understand it our brain we
don't understand even why some foods
work for some people's bodies and other
people's foods other foods don't work
for other people's or why some diets
work or other diet we're learning about
our bodies we're learning about our
brain and when you get to like you know
sex and gender and like the the
implications of our brain and our bodies
and the mix between the two all I'm
saying is let's just keep learning
let's not shut the conversation off
right away yeah but people want to close
that conversation down immediately you
know people want to shut that
conversation off and I'm just one to say
as a voice let's just keep approaching
it let's keep learning it but when that
guy is there and he says that and then
there's like a hundred people on his
friends like yeah yeah he's like
emboldened to be like yeah that's how it
is case that's how it is case closed I
just want to be like there's other
people out here with other opinions and
I'm not saying you're wrong I'm just
saying I think we have a lot more
learning about ourselves to do as humans
you know there's so much more growing
that can be done and I think with all
the fake news and all the all the like
conspiracy theories and the crazy stuff
going on I feel like we're in this place
where I can't say if we're responsible
enough I want us to be responsible
enough to do it on our own and you know
I also don't want to say oh let's go
back to curating it cuz curating it is
we're just putting other people in
charge and are they responsible enough
you know I always I always think about
the subreddit that I always go to it's
called boring dystopia oh yeah yeah it's
really this is it like we're really
fully in that you know it's like 1984 we
always thought it'd be like oh man
they're gonna have cameras in our homes
and we're they're gonna know when we're
doing bad stuff or whatever and it's
like no that's you know we do all have
cameras in our in our homes you know my
TV has a microphone and a camera that's
a Samsung TV
so I could say volume up I'll never do
that yeah don't like each one listen if
you're trying to listen you know and now
they have that like Alexa that follows
me that follows her yeah
singing of subreddits what are your
favorite subjects where are some good
subreddits that people should subscribe
to you if they're not subscribed funny
enough I don't subscribe to subreddits I
just go to them okay but I never hit
some funny like an old man on the
internet yeah I've never subscribed to a
YouTube channel
never I just keep like a mental list
that you go to yeah I go there that's it
if you if you go to it enough YouTube
will just be like recommended you like
oh yeah thanks bro but the subscriber
notifications like I die always felt
like it was a wonky system from the
beginning but I like to go to our slash
action figures okay you know I own the
toy boy yeah sorry guys why you ng T oh
why be a while on Instagram I take
pictures of my toys good pictures
actually I'll vouch for him I actually
really enjoy that Instagram yeah go
there guys I go to action figures and
you'll see picture who people who take
far better pictures than me hmm that I
like to go to I do like to go to cringe
okay
I always thought cringe was a one I used
to go to for four years for cringy
content and it's so funny because like I
would go there it's really funny when
you're Oakridge like oh that's
embarrassing haha we're all making fun
of that person I click the next link and
it's happened twice it's me like
washed-up food guy like hitting on how
to heart and it's like me and Hannah
Hart have this like a relationship like
we're friends you know and it's like
this one piece if you take it out of
context from our entire video where I'm
like making this joke and she's like
playing it up and I'm playing it it just
looks so cringy and awkward but you're
missing the whole five minutes before
and after that's set up to that mm-hmm
but like I'm watching on my hour now
it's me you know or it's like like
douchey food guy and jenna marbles
hosting this terrible show in Toronto on
like I click it and it was like this
hosting thing we did and I'm just like
yeah I could totally see how this would
be cringy you know especially if you
come in with like the mentality that
this sucks but like then I also go on
that side I like like you know watch
those videos it's interesting about
suppurative cringes that like like h3h3
and like PewDiePie like have made such
views off of that subreddit just going
like you know the top the top rated
videos looking at the top rated comments
and you know vocalizing it and
visualizing it into video content which
is what Epic Meal Time did with food
content on the internet just vocalizing
it and visualizing it for everyone else
you know so like I like those sub
reddits they're interesting I like I
always go to gaming yeah I like prequel
memes and sequel memes I was like right
yeah I like like watch another good one
you ever go to mealtime videos no
there's nothing to do with that big meal
time but they're just like Meal Time
videos that are like eight minutes long
12 minutes long like the perfect length
like with buy time Oh music isn't like
videos to watch while you're eating
exactly oh saying you go to mealtime
videos you put it up because like a
great sigh right it's so perfect it's
like I'm writing that down yeah it's
like nine minute documentary on you know
this YouTube channel or something or
sometimes you know that guy that captain
disillusioned I love cats sometimes he
makes great mealtime videos and they'll
just have his time and like you'll sit
there your bike I got a grilled cheese
sandwich I need like six minutes you
know he watches uh presentations he does
like because he gets cults like do
various like presentations like I don't
know I have not he is by far the best
presenter I have ever seen like he has
coordinated like he stays in character
for his presentations and the problem is
Captain disillusion has makeup all over
his face
yes I mean I don't know if you know that
the backstory to Captain disillusion but
he's a robot who could awesome his skin
and just wearing the skin over the top
half of his face which makes it seem
cooler in a way but so a conference he
can't just show up and just do it as
himself he needs to he needs to show up
and if Captain disillusion is gonna give
the conference he's to come up with a
way to make like so for example the most
recent one he's going to take a wormhole
to the conference and he has his intern
Alan at the conference and then the
wormhole messes up and it just swaps
their minds so Alan goes into the mind
or goes into the body of captain
dissolution and captain disillusions
mind goes into the body of Alan so the
intern who was just him with
make up on stage gives the presentation
is Captain dissolution doesn't do the
makeup thing
yeah well without the makeup but in the
auto video he cut see once a while is
captain dissolution in makeup as Alan
like trying to fix stuff on the ship
come back to the stage and continue the
conference this is like that level of
the TED talk or something like yeah he's
in a TED talk to I think I mean yeah we
know a skeptic stock you need to talk in
a second attics conference because you
know obviously his whole channel is kind
of based around skepticism yeah videos
you know tell we were talking about
everything's fake yeah yeah and that's
one guy that I've been watching for like
every like I guess like six years ago or
so like every like year I'd look oh yeah
this guy and I'd watch like five videos
in a row and then I'm like oh yeah this
guy but he never got the love that I
feel like he's really fully deserved
yeah like even just putting on that
makeup I mean yeah it's I mean that's
that's commitment
yeah he likes it he loves it he loves he
loves what he's doing that's good I feel
like he's finally getting the
recognition he's not gonna be huge he's
never gonna be a team tenor but I feel
like he's achieved at least the dream
that he's never gonna get big enough
we're like his big brother will [ __ ] his
girlfriend right maybe it's for the
better but he is uh he is big enough now
where he can need making a living doing
what he's doing full-time okay that's
the dream yeah that's that's the biggest
thing as when people always like oh what
do you want to do like where do you want
to go and I'm like I kind of want to
just continue going where I'm going cuz
I know what I do right now is a pipe
dream for many people even though I have
ambitions and I want to continue doing
it like that's that's how it is like
even for yourself like as much ambition
as you might have where you want to go
from here or how much you can grow or
what quarter digital could be even more
is it's already reached that point where
it's pipe dream status for people yes
very much so I want to continue surfing
that that wave I want to continue doing
that and yeah I do have aspirations they
do have things that I want to keep doing
but I still want to maintain what this
is you know like I want to keep doing it
like I love I love doing what I do I
love that it still exists you know I
love that it's still thing I've never
been one
- chase views I've never been one to
chase money hmm
I've always lacked like strong business
ideals hmm
but we say that but you've been a
successful YouTube business for eight
years
that's this world that we live in I I
would be terrible i watch movies i watch
TV shows I read books and I'm just like
I would suck there like I would suck
like if you got me like like in real
life
yeah like if it was like you know you
have me like in ancient Greece or like
all big man let's show him how to fight
like I'm dead so far you know like I'm
dead so fast or like you know like if it
was like you know like the depression
like I'm not I'm not there on time you
know I'm not a punctual guy and
punctuality is like a very important
business aspect and you know being a
teacher have you ever had a high school
teacher like show up ten minutes late to
class or 15 minutes late to class you're
you're legally allowed to leave if they
do show that's yeah that's that is the
rumor that's why I'd set outside my door
you're not legally allowed to leave I
always said that but like yeah like I I
can thrive and I'm always so happy that
I live in this time in this world I've I
it's not like I am fortunate internally
myself it's like I'm fortunate
externally with the world like now I'm
33 and like you're telling me that like
there's Marvel movies Marvel comics
animes popular video games are popular
the Internet is monstrous like
everything I learnt growing up in high
school that like being in the quote
unquote like friends with cool kids you
know like I played on football and stuff
like that and like I had lots of cool
friends all the things that like I would
have to hide from them or that were
uncool to them or like the cool things
now mmm-hmm you know what I mean like
yeah that look I'm lucky for that I'm
lucky that like you know I could play
video games and make that a job I'm
lucky that I could a Marvel movie can
come out and
I could be like well you know what in
the 90s and I could talk you know about
the 90s marvel world for an hour and put
it up as a video when people want to
watch that look I'm lucky for that stuff
the world that we are in is one that I
was able to thrive in not because of me
but because the things I loved by chance
ended up being the most popular things
in the world you know or in culture that
we are in right now so do you think
there's a bit of a dark side to that
though in the sense that you know they
say mmm if you do what you love for work
you'll never work a day in your life but
the risk is that you take what you love
and you make it work interesting like
I've talked to a couple different video
games streamers I'm like do you guys
play video games for fun when you're not
streaming and most of America no or at
least very different types I do you do I
play video games I'm like oh that's cool
I'm like cool and I get off and then I'm
like then I do things in video games
that I don't do on the stream but then
again I only stream like you know all
the stream like two hours and a day I
don't do the six hour streams so that's
the big difference
but I agree with that like you know what
I was when I first read about
achievements achievements and video
games like you play xbox you unlock an
achievement I read a comparison that
like like if you do something that you
love to obtain something no matter what
it is you will end up resenting the
thing that you love mm-hmm so if you
love eating pizza and you love playing
video games and you have to play video
games to get pizza you will eventually
be mad at video games because sometimes
you just want pizza yeah and you'll get
mad at video games for being in between
you and your pizza and I like I like
filming and laughing and and and
producing and being with my friends and
eating and there was a point where I got
there on Epic Meal Time and it's funny
because it's like documented
unfortunately because we never miss a
week so there's like a couple months
period where I just fully full-on hate
the show I hate the show I hate that it
exists I'm so tired of the character
I'm tired of everything and I didn't
want to exist anymore and then I I was
just fortunate enough to snap out of it
quickly mm-hmm where I was like wait
like this is awesome this is a good
thing you know I forgot like what are
the options what are my other lives this
why it's so important that I did
something before I had a real job quote
unquote before because even though it's
hard work it's not the same as you know
being somewhere at 8 a.m. on someone's
dime to do like a tedious task you know
when I did that full-time and so luckily
I snapped out of it but those months I
experienced it and those months like
that experience is why I understand why
guys who had awesome awesome jobs
working with epicMealTime left
epicMealTime I understand that I'm like
I've been there and I'm also also keen
on people chasing something new or doing
something or you know blossoming or
spreading their wings and doing
something else I'm keen on that also so
I respect that but at the same time like
I always thought that the job offered an
epic meal time for myself or for whoever
worked there is like it's just the best
job like you might find something better
for sure or you might find something
more lucrative but ultimately like
that's a very rare chance because what
we do is like I said we operate on
something that is most people's pipe
dreams
yeah it's hardly find two pipe dreams at
one lifetime of course really is that's
why like you know I've had other
youtubers come to me like you know like
years ago and they're like Epic Meal
Time like you know you should really
separate and go and do something else
cuz you know we used to get two million
views in a week
now it'll get like sometimes 300,000
views or sometimes maybe a million and
if it gets a minute I'm like oh my god
Wow big deal again you know but like
it'll get like 300,000 like yeah you got
to move on but the way I see it is like
300,000 people give a [ __ ] like you know
what this realisation of 300,000 people
is in a room yeah make sure it I just
sign a thousand cards like 50 was way
more than I thought fifty would be a
thousand took me hours yeah yeah
that's just a thousand like a thousand
views on a video doesn't seem like a lot
of views Meowth if you have to sign each
card for each person it's like Oh see
and you know what what's funny is like
when you when you have a Bar Mitzvah
unique oh when you have a barman time
and I finally have my bar mitzvah they
you have to write a thank-you card it's
just tradition to everyone that went
there and like I had a big bar mix with
like 300 people so it took like a month
of like an hour after school every day
like sitting down and maybe
subconsciously that resonated with me
the value of one view mm you know and I
sat there and I went and I like was like
thank you for coming it means so much to
me Harley Morenstein 300 times like oh
my god that's insane it is it really is
so when you see furniture styles and
views you know I I feel bad for some
youtubers that were like top like you
know the number one channel on YouTube
and there was a time when Epic Meal Time
was the most watched channel on YouTube
and it's like some channels there's just
like they're younger and they're like oh
the views the views the views and they
get obsessed the views and they want the
views and that's so important and then
their views drop and they're like only
getting 800,000 views and I know that
they're panicking I know that they're
freaking out like I know some youtubers
have looked at Epic Meal Time been like
oh god I hope that's never me I hope I
never fall to 300,000 views hmm
that would be terrible you know but like
at the same time Epic Meal Time is more
lucrative today than it ever was maybe
with the jerky and maybe with like you
know the trust from brands and stuff
like that but I'm so happy that I stuck
with it and I never got caught up in
that like you know I I would watch lots
of YouTube's I would watch lots of
phousi and you know uh you know god
bless him I would watch his videos and
you know he had the most views on
YouTube and then he went from like the
most views on YouTube to a new
generation coming like someone like rice
come come one views and rice come called
him irrelevant and like it flipped him
upside down you know and as someone
who's been called irrelevant by rice
come as well like you know I saw that no
no that's funny it's but for him it like
it was like
it was like the rug was ripped out from
under him like some people go on YouTube
and think that you know and they'll be
number one they think they'll be number
one forever like I know like I just know
that you know Jake Paul will not be
number one on YouTube forever I know
that you know Logan epaulet would not be
number one forever you know what I mean
mm-hmm I think one of my favorite
channels PewDiePie like he's got like an
incredible work ethic and I think his
content is really relevant III like
watching him a lot and I think that's
someone who is more of an anomaly than
anyone else I've seen on YouTube because
he's like I've never seen someone surf
it so well over the years I've never
seen someone continued to adapt and
evolve and do it daily and surf it like
so well that I I'm curious how he would
react if he was not there anymore you
know like or how we passed it by
t-series here yeah I know right even by
the time this comes out who knows but
like I just like I know some youtubers
they chase those views they chase the
subscribers and I've never been that
going back like what I said before I've
never chased money view subscribers
because unless is void and you'll never
fill it and even if you get ten million
now you'll want a hundred million and
then you want a billion and then you'll
want to billion and no matter what
you'll never be able to fill that void
and so what I've always chased is
surviving another day doing it mm-hmm
just surviving another day and if it
means that like I can't get the best
camera or the best computer this time
work I have to do more work or I have to
replace some or whatever it is no matter
what or if I have to move cities doing
it another day another month is the most
important thing to me and I am like I
almost ly feel like in some ways I'm
gonna bore bore owed time where I'm like
man this could have ended four years ago
and I'm like that was so crazy I never
thought that would happen in life you
know but like here it is eight years
later I always said epicMealTime would
be done in five years since you can't
they make a bacon joke for more than
five years
you know now we're like eight years and
I'm just like I'm like I know it'll go
for ten I'm gonna stretch it till ten
you know and then and once epic meal has
been around for ten years it's like [ __ ]
Epic Meal Time has been around longer
than WCW nitro kids grew up watching WCW
nitro like their whole life their whole
childhood but every mealtime might be
around longer than that and like you
know and I just want to survive
continuing doing what I love and like
you said before like it's just a dream
like that is the dream like gotten
disillusioned doing what he what he
wants as a living yeah you know do you
have that worried that like next year
the brand deals might stop or that cuz
it's kind of an unknown out there you
know it's always evolving like you live
on that anxiety are you pretty
comfortable no I've been there I've been
past those I've been past the times
where there's like no brand deals you
know where brand deals are at a minimum
where they just don't come through I've
seen like our number be it one number
and then go down to like 25% that value
and I'm like let's do it and then I've
seen it go back up to what it was again
it's like I've been there before so like
I mean as as ridiculous as it sounds
there's cockys it sounds like going into
Epic Meal Time and of everyone that's
ever been on Epic Meal Time I to friends
I'd sterling who we started it with and
then you met sterling that first day I
met you I think the reason I remember
that day so clearly is because both you
and sterling are very tall yeah thank
you very tall men really tall Canadian
dudes yeah just like we're on the
mountain to be fair like you were on
back then you were one of the bigger
personalities and honestly that's the
part out the right way to put it you
were more clearly a character than
almost anyone else on YouTube at the
time everyone else was kind of a nerdy
kid trying to figure out I know you're
also a nerdy kid but like you didn't
seem like a nerdy kid in your channel
you actually seemed like somebody
stepped from would you should be a TV
position into YouTube and you're one of
those like first people to stand out
like that you know you were very clearly
a big character and like that sit out to
me too because I hadn't met anybody else
like that on YouTube mm-hmm yeah thank
you it's true when I went to VidCon and
I met a lot of youtubers I girl like you
I love you Charlie
then three years later they're wearing
like all Gucci they're like so bad but I
did watch a lot of youtubers like change
in that sense you know but I remember my
first VidCon I go up like yo what's up
[Music]
then literally they're like pulling up
in like the dopest cars three years
later and like you know like it sets in
but I I know what you meant like I know
what you mean it was like a rare it was
a rare channel at the time Epic Meal
Time it was it was rare at the time it
was different it was like you either
like you know if you were a face you
were like what's up guys I'm suiting my
cereal we'll play my little acoustic
guitar and sing you guys a song I wrote
you know it was like a different time it
was it was it was different but my
friends were you know sterling and we
had a falling out but we cleared that we
cleared the air there and like you know
him and I we've hung out a couple times
since then and my other friend going
into was a mirror mm-hmm and a mirror
still on Epic Meal Time I'm like let me
know likes to say god I picked me FeO
he's just a mere one the Epic Meal Time
Hunger Games so like he's like no matter
what like you know me or one that I'm
against again means like you know me I'm
yours clutch Amir was cooking on Epic
Meal Time at the beginning and then he
went to editing then he went back to
cooking and so the reason why I bring it
up is that like you know when I said I
just want to continue doing what I'm
doing at the end of the day is like all
I need is this iPhone and a mirror mm-hm
and like we have an epic Meal Time
Channel yeah and I definitely do not
want to discount like you know like Mike
Santos Tanner rush like guys that I work
with now
you know my cousin Justin who produces
on Epic Meal Time now I definitely don't
discount that at all
they make it quality they make it better
but in its most basic form at the end of
the day all I need is this phone and a
mirror and we're good but I feel so bad
about like you know Smosh like Ian
Anthony is like the bank-owned Smosh now
it's like Smosh is dead yeah but it's
like damn all Ian needs is a cellphone
for something to be Smosh mm-hmm that's
it you know yeah
do you find the like you and a mirror
you guys are still friends outside of
being on the show you still hang out
huge yeah big friends yeah talk all the
time like you know like the office that
we have is like you know it's like a
setup similar to this but like me and
Amir like often sleep there you know
what I mean we play video games on and
off camera speaking of the achievements
and like something like being made to
make you resent something
Amir hates video games he went on he
went he loved video games he used to
chase achievements those so much he
liked chase them for like four years and
then just like completely like just
broke down like and he'll never admit it
but he just he won't even touch a
PlayStation game cuz you can't get it
achievements he despises PC but like
he'll play xbox and like he'll still
chase the achievements and I'll black
o'keefe mint and he'll but I don't care
there's a lot it's really weird I feel
like Amir is teach me a lot of truths
about life yeah a very honest guy yeah
and I can tell him he make a good video
because of how he reacts to it yeah yeah
but Amir is also like he's like Amir's
like like he's also he's the core fan
but he's also like the one that he might
not even like if you really got to know
mm-hmm like I'd be like yo new quarter
vigil at Newark new quarter of videos
that was great he's like yeah like what
it's not good he's like no guns
so like because of that like he
completely missed out on how awesome the
fidgets bitter one was because he's so
one-track minded about it you know what
I mean but like that he likes what he
likes he knows what he likes yeah I mean
like he's like you know he's got his his
firearms he's got his his the things
that he loves and things that he
respects he definitely watches your
videos the instant they come out you
know because I don't subscribe he'll
tell me
yeah when there's a new one he's the
bell for you
yeah Amir is actually the bell for so
many things a lot of my shortcomings in
the business world are ones that Amir
has mm-hmm so am ears like extremely
punctual mm-hmm Amir is great at time
management you know I'm good at I'm good
at communication
I'm good at you know like encouraging
people empowering people you know but I
do think that I lack some elements of
being a good leader to an extent and
over the years I just recognized I'll
recognize some patterns about like you
know what some people will get mad at me
over or what some people won't be happy
about or whatever or things like that
you know mm-hmm and like I guess I could
be like ruthless unintentionally with
certain things you know what I mean
laughs but that like if you mess
if you mess with Epic Meal Time or like
you have something like that or a
problem with Epic Meal Time like like I
said it's so important to me that I do
this everyday like then I'll never hold
a grudge but I'll burn a bridge
all right lower like you'll burn a
bridge with me the bridge is burned and
you could always I've had people who've
been on Epic Meal Time who've left up
Epic Meal Time come back to me and
apologize for how it went down and then
I've had other people that like you know
I will know firsthand they'll go and
they'll they'll talk [ __ ] about me or
they'll talk [ __ ] about epicMealTime and
like I'll remember that mm-hmm you know
I do remember in one specific scenario
like so him being like Oh Harley's a bad
person hmm Harley's not good because you
know they had a brand deal for with a
cooking company to do some cooking stuff
but I heard about it so I went to that
company and I said Amir we'll do it and
I brought it to a mirror and that person
lost that deal and I gained that deal
hmm now I don't think that makes me a
bad person the way I see it is like it's
in the business realm you're not on my
team Amir is my friend and is on my team
and he can do it and so I leveraged my
power quote unquote or I leveraged my
brand to take a brand deal from someone
and give it to one of my people yeah and
like knowing that that that no but I do
understand why that person would go and
say I am a bad person for that because
that's bad for them but at the same time
it's like you know I this is what I do
like I'll bring it to Epic Meal Time
like I'll bring it to my guys I'll bring
it to us
you know wolf
run away to do what make it happen for
ourselves like I said like I want the
people that have been on my team and are
on my team to make the most of it to
experience the best parts of it you know
and I remember like I always compared to
Vince McMahon who's not like you know a
nice guy quote-unquote but it's
definitely a business guy far more
business than I would ever be but he
always said like you know wrestlers
would want guarantees they like all want
to be guaranteed this that this that and
you know in terms of money and his
saying was that I don't I don't give
guarantees I give opportunities mm-hmm
and that's always been the epicMealTime
thing epicMealTime is just like every
mealtime can't guarantee you anything
but Epic Meal Time can give you an
opportunity you know people have left
Epic Meal Time and gone on to do like
incredible things that maybe they wanted
to have done if it wasn't for Epic Meal
Time and I know this firsthand because I
have opportunities that I would have
never done if it wasn't for Epic Meal
Time you know I would have never been in
Kevin Smith movies if it wasn't for Epic
Meal Time were filmed with Arnold
Schwarzenegger multiple times James
Franco Seth Rogen if it wasn't for Epic
Meal Time you know yeah I wouldn't get
to cut the line at the Cheesecake
Factory because the hostess recognized
me if it wasn't for Epic Meal Time do
you get recognized pretty often on the
street yeah I have I have a face yeah
like I have a look at a face you know so
when I go to like when I was at the
Cheesecake Factory five tastes ago huge
lineup and like I walked there I was
like oh how long's the wait and he was
like oh it'll be 40 minutes and he
looked at me as like oh [ __ ] I'll sit
you right now Oh like with Andy I was
like see this is what it's all about
nice so do you feel like you're famous
how funny is that and you know what I
used to have a hard time because it's
like what is what a stupid thing to to
say I'm famous I would say yes I would
say so are you I would say that the
reason why I would say that is because
that is the world we live in
mm-hmm I am famous you are famous but
wouldn't say we are celebrities with
that so that's how I would say it but it
the reason why I said is because look I
know this girl with like a big ass and
she puts like protein shakes on her ass
and bends over and takes a picture for
Instagram she is very famous mm-hmm by
definition by definition by definition
that is a definition like you know like
it's just I know them and there are so
many people I follow on Instagram they
are famous and how many people on
tik-tok with like 20 million Instagram
followers that like you've never heard
their name or seen their face before
doesn't matter it's not about you
they're famous like there's just famous
Fame is so famous everywhere it's
literally everywhere
I wanted celebrity then celebrity is
celebrity is this like it's a different
level it's like you're not even like
like you know who's here's you knows
just becoming celebrity like just
getting into that is that kid Ezra that
played flash in DC movies he is like
just breaking into celebrity Chris Pratt
has been enjoying celebrity for for a
couple years now you know what I mean
anyone in the Marvel movies like you
know celebrity you know what I mean
yeah but then there's this a level of
consistency consistency in my eyes that
make it a celebrity you know like Chris
Pratt has that you know what I mean like
we're dealt kind of broke into that the
past couple of years I feel like Weird
Al deserves so much more than he gets
yeah you know he's not on the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame really yeah it's not
weird I feel like he should be I feel
like I don't know Weird Al weird I was
like weird out something I think of
Weird Al and like Andy Milonakis like
people that existed in our time mm-hmm
that are just like now are just like
would be just another YouTube channel
style thing mm-hmm
you know what I mean yeah like we're
lucky because we have Weird Al but the
kids these days they have like Bart
Baker I mean it's like if they're like
they're the same thing ultimately but
we're now is just like
he did it at a time where there was a
middleman like he had to go an audition
and pitch and he didn't just like throw
it up and like game a system there was
no game you had to you have to convince
people yeah that are like you know jaded
and look at multiple people every single
day and yeah there's a grind there too
or it's like you're doing that over and
over and over and over for years Weird
Al's beyond celebrity he's like icon
yeah I think I do know that just because
we're of his era yeah yeah no he's an
icon that you can't take that from I
think we're great I think like you know
then there's like then there's
celebrities but then there are people
that are celebrities but like they're
like icons Arnold Schwarzenegger
Sylvester Stallone you feel that Arnold
Schwarzenegger yeah and Eve even if
today they're not as us as as famous as
you know Chris Pratt or like you know
like they are it's just something that a
level that can't be taken away you know
what I mean like Chris Pratt is now at a
level where it can't be taken away you
know what I mean it's just it's too much
Jim Carrey is an icon also they're part
of culture exactly it's it's it's like
so deep you know yeah that's why I said
that kid the who plays the flash Ezra
Miller because I feel like he's getting
there and if he has like a couple a
couple decisions in his career like then
he becomes that you know that full-on
celebrity status you know I think he
already is a celebrity mm-hmm but you
know I I can't you know I think I think
Logan Paul and Jake Paul are celebrities
ya know I think I think if I would
expand on what you're saying I think a
celebrity requires you to have that that
touch on people that puts you into into
culture and this is interesting like at
almost the rock is almost not quite
there like I think he's done enough and
he's doesn't been on the grind for so
long that he's a celebrity but he's
never quite had to Schwarzenegger moment
he's never had his t2 he's gotten close
he's got a couple ways I've been close
but he's
I think the biggest problem with him is
like cuz as close as he comes he get you
get like the skyscraper in the rampage
mm-hmm and maybe that's what like slows
that process down like one step forward
two steps back sounds like he's too much
of a businessman mmm like he's making
movies that are bringing in huge budgets
and like keeping the whole The Rock
Machine going you know the seven bucks
machine yeah but I feel like he just he
needs a little bit of that moment where
he stops being a businessman and starts
trying to make something that I feel
like he's gonna be in so let me play
like he's got a movie coming up a
superhero movie and I feel like that's
like the fast track to celebrity these
days yeah he's like you do a celebrity
movie and then you do like like like
like you then you win an Oscar for
something else and then it's like you're
there Ryan Gosling
Ryan Gosling I feel like is so ingrained
in culture and so many people know him
and his is like his movies you know like
that I feel like he's he's celebrity you
know what I mean
yeah I feel like he's like he's up there
as well yeah a lot of people like for a
lot of people drive is their favorite
film exactly and I think when you're in
something like that where you connect
with people in that deep I have a
notebook also oh yeah yeah I actually
have never seen the notebook
oh you haven't I highly recommend it
yeah I know it's like such an LA no I
definitely recommend watching the book
it's really good it's a very good movie
I'm sure it's very well made
IV wood will be overjoyed for me to sit
down with her one evening and watch it
with her night maybe Monday it's a good
one I don't remember it puts that one
off for a while another one I put off
for a while was Brokeback Mountain oh
yeah didn't like it wasn't good no feel
like angley's little hit or miss just
wasn't it wasn't my thing but it was
also like with like all you know POW you
gotta check out I'm like okay usually
Brokeback Mountain you got you but it's
like I don't want to watch these movies
because they're gay literally it's about
to game in and the other one is like Oz
what love come on but then I ended up
watching them mm-hmm and yeah did the
same director do the notebook that's
Brooke mountain no they were just two
movies that were recommended to me that
I remember everyone talking about over a
period of time and I was like I don't
need that in my life
I find it strange that the same director
of robic mountain also did the Hulk
movie The Hulk yeah the big Hulk where
he just keeps growing and doesn't stop
growing right yeah I think so yeah yes
very clearly purple pants yeah yeah at
the risk of asking a super vague
question I mean I'm a huge Ross integra
fan what was he like he was really
really excellent so I don't know if you
know but the first thing I ever saw in
theaters was Terminator 2 mm-hmm
so the only what's that what a movie I
know the only movie the only reason why
I do what I do today or I am where I am
today is because I saw Terminator 2 at 5
years old and I walked out of that movie
and I was like that's what I want to do
when I'm older mm-hmm I want to make
movies I want to be in movies I want to
write and wanted that so cool I want to
do that like I want to I just know
that's what I want to do and I'm like
I'll make a movie with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and my dad said oh so
clear you came to the movie so what's
the plot and I was like what's the plot
and I was like six and I remember him
explaining to me what the plot is and
the word the plot and just that whole
interaction of seen terminator what's
the plot and you know just being like oh
she's like thinking about movies from
that day forward you know my dad had a
video camera and like I always mess
around with the video camera when I was
going to school I would like bring in
projects that use the video camera
instead of doing the regular regular
presentation would be a movie a video
presentation and that's what made me
want to do it so being filming with
Arnold Schwarzenegger it was so
incredible and so awesome and like the
one thing that I didn't expect was he
enjoyed it oh yeah and the reason why he
enjoyed it was because I got there and I
was fan Fanning boy fanboying like
big-time and I was like really excited
and I was like explaining how excited I
was and I was apologizing for being
excited blow onions I got really it's
okay it's okay I thought I found out
like from his people that like in this
day and age of like Dwayne Johnson's
Channing Tatum's Chris Evans and Chris
Pratt's like
he's happy to come across people like me
hmm that are like you're the [ __ ] God
bro you're the guy man
this all this [ __ ] only because of you
man only people who use guns and movies
cuz he like you know like he he liked
that and I got to I got to share some
really extreme jokes there's like I had
some extreme jokes written for
epicMealTime and so I shared these
extreme jokes with his assistant
mm-hm and he was like he's got a twisted
sense of humor he's like go share it to
him so I did I went and shared it with
him and he loved it he laughed and then
he started to tell me something that was
kind of messed up and it ended up being
a joke and it was hilarious and I just I
grasp like that he's got like a really
twisted sense of humor but he was so
great he was really awesome and then we
got to film with him twice and Amir
brought his predator blu-ray mm-hm and
like he signed it and everything and
he's awesome he is it the game like
Austria gave him a tank Austria like yes
a tank this is Schwarzenegger on it
that's pretty cool I have men he's
awesome I love him what's crazy is like
what you don't realize is you know I
grew up watching him five years old it
ended up being a thing and I ended up
doing what I do today because of him
what's interesting about youtubers today
is like they've experienced that with
your channel or maybe my channel they
were 10 yeah and now they're 18 and they
left high school and they've made their
life decision based on the videos that
they watched of yours or mine and that's
what's interesting to me is that when I
pick mealtime first started I was just
like our having fun we're goofing off
but like in 2010 a common comment would
be like wow no girls in the kitchen
which it seems so crazy to say that now
but that's where 2010 was at yeah they
thought the kitchen was for girls to
make me a sammich you [ __ ] loser
[ __ ] dumb things so like they would
say that to us like that would be a
common comment about like oh yeah you
know what are you doing let's get some
girls in the kitchen I didn't realize it
at the time but you know there was like
kale organic food blah blah blah it was
such a it was a contaminating food
because if you wanted to get in the
kitchen and cook and you weren't Jamie
Oliver then you were gonna have Gordon
Ramsay yell at you for [ __ ] up the
whole meal it was scary it was like you
going to get you're gonna get yelled at
Gordon Ramsay's gonna be pissed yeah so
don't go in the kitchen less you knew
what you were doing but we got in the
kitchen we goofed off and I know people
were like hey if this idiots going to
the kitchen and I can go in the kitchen
you know and I think about people that
watched Epic Meal Time and they'd be
like they would send me like their chef
knife tattoo I'd be like I just
graduated from culinary school when it
cuz of Epic Meal Time we ended up being
like those people that brought we
introduced people into the culinary
world you know yeah I know this guy
Fabio used to come to like our shoots
when he was younger like literally
dressed like mussels glass things now I
see him he puts up pictures like I even
commented on one of them I was like bro
if I'm the sauce boss I'm like you're
the pasta master just always making
these custom pastas and stuff you know
way beyond what I would ever be able to
do or would anyone on the shows be able
to do because he grew up on Epic Meal
Time and watched and like learn from it
and like pursued something because of it
I could just imagine any type of people
that probably were gonna go and buy
something and instead decided to save up
and get a camera because of your channel
or something of the sort you know they
decided to make a decision based on how
you inspired them and I don't think
about this much I don't know if you
thought about it but I had someone he
was saw me at the mall he must have been
like 17 he was like oh my god you're
here and I was like yeah he's like my
childhood man you're my childhood and I
didn't think about that but when you're
in elementary school time goes very slow
it feels like a lifetime yeah cuz it's
like 90% of your life back then yeah you
know but like those five years watching
Epic Meal Time for him that was his
childhood like the people that would
watch corridor digital through it all
Elementary are all high school the
impact that
channel has on them like you know you
end up inspiring people you know like
Logan Paul Jake Paul they grew up
watching YouTube they grew up watching
people on YouTube mm-hmm so it's just
like we've you know we've kind of like
made a little a little rift in how
society will be moving forward by
introducing new new players in the game
in one way or another that will follow
paths that we've done not that like I'm
hyping us up like oh we're so great it's
just a matter of fact like you know
there's a billion views on Epic Meal
Time you know there's millions of
subscribers people watched it and people
will be affected yeah you know and I
don't know if you ever think about it's
really trippy I do I mean it actually it
makes me really happy and back when I
was going to college like right before I
was leaving it's done with high school
my grandma I call her Mamie my Mamie
it was your grandfather pip-pip no he
was just grandpa she's french-canadian
she's from Quebec so she got Mamie she's
usually super supportive and very kind
and loving and sweet but she pulled me
aside and unusually for her she said
what are you going to do it's going to
help people how is how is what you're
gonna go off to do here with filmmaking
how's that gonna make any difference in
the world and it's like well I've never
been challenged by maymay before but
when I hear stories like what you're
saying here that makes me think back to
that conversation you know and if if
you've helped inspire people to pursue
what they want to do or we've helped
inspire inspire people to do what they
want to do that's helping people and I'm
glad that that's helping people and I
hope it continues to work that way so I
agree I agree with that it's like one of
those things were like back in the day
people like well how does this help in
there like it make people laugh makes
people smile and I bet gather it's good
but this is a deeper thing if it gives
people fulfillment but I'm happy about
that also and you know I know firsthand
because some people would message me
when you just look at the numbers of it
all like it's just simple statistics
some people will base their life on
being like you know like you know there
two kids out there there are kids out
there that are friends and I kill we got
to be like core or digital mm-hmm how
Sam and Nico do it and they go back and
they look at your life story and they're
like how did they do it where did they
go what did they do and they're like try
and walk in your footsteps because they
want to they're happy with where you are
right now and they want to be like that
when they're older mm-hmm you know yeah
well I hope we continue inspire people
like that this is very I feel like this
is like 33 year old youtubers like this
is how you look at the kids Matt it's
it's for the kids yeah I know yeah well
guys I think it's a really positive note
to end this podcast on go out there and
make a difference and inspire people to
do good things right exactly
yeah well Harley thanks for coming out
and sharing some these insights and
stories on the world and what it means
to be a youtuber in this day and age and
what videos mean to culture and all that
kind of stuff it's been a really
insightful and interesting conversation
I appreciate you coming out and joining
us in the podcast thank you so much for
having me did I ramble I felt like I
rambled so much that's what this is all
about that's what a podcast is I guess
right yeah about the interesting
ramblings I mean there's a pretty
interesting rambling this is like a
ramble down a path like a cliff on one
side and some mountains in the distance
like it was a really is a path really
worth rambling down for a while yeah
yeah thank you so much cool man thanks
for having me bro you bet big thank you
to Harley Morenstein for joining us on
the corridor cast as a pleasure talking
to you Harley and I hope to see you back
some time to delve into some further
theories and life experiences that you
might have to share with us if you are
subscribed to our YouTube channel thank
you very much if not please head over to
youtube.com slash corredor cast and
subscribe not only do we have every
episode up there with video if we also
have highlight some cool little tidbits
taken from each podcast and if you would
like to listen to us on your favorite
podcast service we are available there
as well whether it's Spotify iTunes
Google podcasts or whatever it's called
we're on all of them so go check us out
all right thank you so much hope to see
you in the next podcast thank you